what do you make of the hostile
relationship that to me at least stands
out of the presidents between donald
trump and the cia
was that a very kind of
personal
bickering i mean is there something
interesting to you about the dynamics
between that particular president and
that particular instantiation of the
intelligence agency man there were lots
of things fascinating to me about that
that relationship so first what's the
good and the bad sergeant so let me
start with the good first because
there's a lot of people who don't think
there was any good
so the good thing is
we saw
that
the president who's the chief
customer the executive to the cia
when the president doesn't want to hear
what cia has to say he's not going to
listen
i think that's an important lesson for
everyone to
take home
if the president doesn't care what you
have to say he's going to take funding
away or she will take funding away
they're going to take attention away
they're going they're going to
shut down
your operations your missions they're
going to kill the careers of the people
working there think about that for the
four years that president trump was the
president
basically everybody at cia their career
was put on pause some people's careers
were ended some people voluntarily left
their career there
because they found themselves working
for a single customer that didn't want
what they had to produce so for people
who don't know
uh donald trump did not display
significant deep interest in the output
uh he did not trust it yeah he was a
disinterested customer exactly right
information and then what do
disinterested customers do they go find
someone else to create their product and
that's exactly what donald trump did and
he did it through the private
intelligence world funding private
intelligence companies to run their own
operations that brought him the
information he cared about when cia
wouldn't it also didn't help that cia
stepped outside of their confines right
cia's supposed to collect foreign
intelligence and not comment on domestic
matters they went way outside of that
when they started challenging the
president when they started questioning
the results when they started
publicly claiming russian influence
that's all something the fbi could have
handled by itself the justice department
could have handled by itself cia had no
place
to contribute to that conversation and
when they did all they did was undermine
the relationship they had with their
primary customer
you